wenn ich abends in den nachthimmel
schauer und mir die millionen und
abermillionen von sternen ansehe da
komme ich mir schnell sehr klein vor ich
bin einfach nur erschlagen von dem
gedanken daran wie unvorstellbar groß
das universum eigentlich ist aber mit
diesem gedanken dass jeder einzelne von
diesen kleinen weißen punkten eigentlich
eine riesige sonne ist und um all diese
sonnen auch noch mehrere planeten
kreisen kommt mir sehr schnell der
gedanke von anderen lebensformen
irgendwo da draußen muss doch etwas sein
aber wieso haben wir noch nie etwas
gehört sind wir komplett allein
herzlich willkommen zu einer weiteren
folge watson allein im beobachtbaren
teil des universums gibt es je nach
schätzung zwischen 100 und 400
milliarden galaxien und in jeder dieser
galaxien gibt es ungefähr noch einmal so
viele sterne
das bedeutet dass es insgesamt zwischen
10 hoch 22 und 10 24 sterne gibt
anders ausgedrückt für jedes sandkorn
hier auf der erde gibt es ungefähr
10.000 sterne in unserem universum wenn
man bedenkt wie viele dieser sterne
unserer sonne ähnlich sind und wie viele
dieser sterne planeten haben die in der
bewohnbaren zone ihrer sterne kreisen
dann kommt man selbst mit der
konservativsten schätzung auf 100
millionen erdähnliche planeten nun wie
wahrscheinlich ist die entstehung von
leben auf einem planeten
keiner weiß das so wirklich selbst wir
haben uns mit unserer fortgeschrittenen
technologie noch nicht geschafft leben
auf molekularer ebene aus dem nichts zu
erschaffen
wenn wir also die chance für das
entstehen von leben mit ein und prozent
bewerten könnten wir extrem übertrieben
aber ich meine wir brauchen hier eine
zahl ähnlich sieht es mit der chance für
intelligentes leben aus wie
wahrscheinlich ist es dass sich eine
lebensform zu einer abstrakt denkenden
lebensform weiterentwickelt und auf
höheren ebenen miteinander kommunizieren
kann
auch hier erst mal der platzhalter 1
prozent all das würde bedeuten dass im
universum zehn milliarden also 10 hoch
intelligente lebensformen existieren
allerdings würden diese aufgrund der
expansion des universums extrem lange
brauchen um uns zu erreichen
selbst mit super high tech
raketenantriebe alle galaxien in diesem
universum driften so schnell auseinander
dass es milliarden von jahren dauern
würde
zwischen den galaxien hin und her zu
reisen also beziehung uns am besten
erstmal nur auf unsere eigene galaxie
die milchstraße
wenn wir hier dieselbe mathematik an
wänden kommen wir auf 100.000
intelligente lebensformen in unserer
direkten nachbarschaft die hier irgendwo
rum fliegen müssten 100.000 lebensformen
von denen zumindest ein paar doch auch
mal wissen wollen würden was da draußen
noch so alles ist oder nicht
die vor allem teilweise mehr zeit gehabt
haben müssen um sich weiterzuentwickeln
100 jahre sind im vergleich zur
lebensdauer des universums nichts nicht
mal ein blind
und doch haben wir den letzten 100
jahren so unglaublich viel über das
universum erfahren wir können uns gar
nicht vorstellen was wir in zwanzig
geschweige denn 100 jahren alles wissen
werden wie unterschiedlich wusste eine
technische fortschritt von lebensformen
sein die schon seit millionen von jahren
im all umherreisen nun es gibt zwei
möglichkeiten warum wir noch nichts von
außerirdischem leben gehört haben und um
aphasie klagt zu zitieren
beide sind gleich schrecklich zum einen
gibt es die möglichkeit dass es einfach
keine höheren lebensformen gibt
vielleicht ist das entstehen von leben
so wie wir es kennen einfach so
unwahrscheinlich dass es selbst bei der
milliarde von bewohnbaren planeten in
unserer galaxie
nur ein einziges mal geschehen ist oder
das entstehen von intelligentem leben
ist beinahe unmöglich und auf jedem
zweiten bewohnbaren planeten gibt es
tiere die einfach ihr leben leben ohne
einen gedanken an das universum zu
verschwenden
solche würden oder auch filter
verhindern dass eine große anzahl an
verschiedenen lebensformen kontakt zur
außenwelt aufnehmen kann
wenn das entstehen von leben dieser
große filter ist dann haben ihn bereits
passiert und sind vielleicht die erste
zivilisation die das weltall erkundet
leider gibt es aber auch die möglichkeit
dass diese filter noch vor uns liegen
atomkrieges globale erderwärmung oder
irgend eine technologie die wir noch gar
nicht kennen könnte dazu führen dass wir
uns selber auslöschen werden
und dann gibt es noch die möglichkeit
dass es sehr wohl sehr viele
intelligente lebensformen dort draußen
gibt vielleicht sind wir aber einfach
nicht wichtig genug um beachtet zu
werden oder vielleicht verstehen wir die
signale der außerirdischen nicht ähnlich
wie eine katze nicht mal annähernd
verstehen kann was ein computer ist oder
was eine e mail auf diesem bildschirm zu
tun hat es könnte auch sein dass es nur
eine einzige super mächtige lebensformen
im universum gibt und dass diese jeder
andere lebensform auslöst sobald ein
gewisser technologischer stand erreicht
wird vielleicht sind sie jetzt schon auf
dem weg zu uns seitdem wir die ersten
signale ins all geschickt haben
oder und das finde ich besonders
interessant die theorie dass jede
intelligente lebensform nach einer
gewissen zeit die virtuelle realität
entdeckt hat und sich entschieden hat
ihr leben nicht in dieser sondern in
einer schönen und perfekten welt zu
verbringen
in der eigenen matrix anstelle eines
riesigen toten weltalls kann man doch
auch in einer schönen und perfekten welt
voller glück leben
was meint ihr wieso haben wir noch
nichts von anderen lebensformen gehört
was ist eure theorie schreibst du auf
jeden fall unten in die kommentare hier
rechts findet dann noch die meinen
letzten videos von nordson rangers
interessiert und ansonsten könnt ihr
hier oben ein kostenloser service von
apple bekommen und uns dafür
gleichzeitig auch noch unterstützen
ansonsten wenn ihr noch hier seid könnt
ihr das video gerne positiv oder negativ
bewerten je nachdem wie es euch gefallen
hat und ich sage vielen dank fürs
zuschauen und bis zum nächsten mal